un report des élections départementales
et régionales au mois de juin 2021 a été
acté c'est la conclusion du rapport
rendu au premier ministre par jean louis
debré l'ancien président du conseil
constitutionnel a auditionné des
représentants politiques scientifiques
et administratifs une décision qui fait
consensus 1 dans la sphère politique
écouter l'un des principaux intéressés
dans le département des yvelines
interrogé par nos confrères de radio
sensations depuis plusieurs semaines je
dis à mes collègues présidents de
conseils départementaux que le pire
serait de reproduire ce qui s'est passé
en mars dernier pour les élections
municipales
car nous perdrions la confiance de nos
concitoyens donc organisons ces
élections étaient fin du printemps pour
la campagne électorale c'est à dire le
mois de mai élections au mois de juin
posons aussi la question de savoir s'il
ne serait pas intelligent de séparer des
élections départementales et régionales
dans ce rapport on retrouve plusieurs
recommandations d'abord le gouvernement
devra fixer et annoncer publiquement la
nouvelle date du scrutin
le parlement devra donc discuter d'un
projet de loi présenté par l'exécutif
les parlementaires pourront débattre à
la fois sur les conditions
d'organisation du scrutin et de la
campagne écoutez à ce propos la
sénatrice des yvelines martha de cidre
est qu il me semble que le point sur
lequel il faut que nous soyons très
attentifs c'est les modalités de la
campagne puisque une campagne en période
crise sanitaire très clairement ne se
passera pas de la même manière qu'en
temps normal
et pour les candidats il faut qu'ils se
sentent tous dans la capacité de pouvoir
la mener au mieux avec des moyens je
dirais les plus équivalent les plus
équitable possible pour que chacun
puisse se faire entendre
enfin un rapport du conseil scientifique
kobe de 10,9 sur la situation sanitaire
devra être remis à la proche du scrutin